[Music]
the hospitals are full and the truly
sick keep on arriving the only sound is
the urgent movement of the medical teams
and the machines keeping the patient's
alive desperately ill each breath is a
struggle this is the reality of the
deepening crisis Spain is facing many of
the patients are unconscious they're
turned on their front to improve their
chances of survival the first step that
we take doing that improves in each beds
the battle for life is played out lonely
Wars with no loved ones by the bedside
the infectiousness of the novel
coronavirus makes sure of that doctors
do their best but even something as
simple as the human touch is difficult
in these conditions if you need all this
this is called for for management the
patients if you need innovative you need
budakh as a very unique very maneuvers
complicated maneuvers it is very very
difficult to ward of this this close
spain watched in horror of what was
happening in italy but is now following
in that country's footsteps in fact the
outbreak may soon be even worse already
more people are infected with the corona
virus when you come to these wards you
understand when you look at the patients
in intensive care
just how overwhelmed the healthcare
system in this country has been day
after day patient after patient they
just keep on coming and to give you an
idea of how bad it is at this hospital
more than 75% of the patients now are
covered 19 the majority of the
hospital's capacity is now dealing with
the corona virus the doctors like in
what's happening here to a natural
disaster but one which does not stop one
every day coming 6070 patients with
severe conditions every doctor here even
the you know the surgeons the the
urologists the ophthalmologists have
been taking care of medical patients
respiratory patients which is very
unusual even students medical students
in the last year of their careers have
been recruited to take care of these
patients a good outcome he's down to the
skill of the clinicians but they also
admit that when dealing with a virus
that was unknown to the world just a few
months ago luck also plays its parts
Andrea is lucky he came here gasping for
air but is now recovering they come to
the hospital
I once I get through the hospital
doctors say this nation like nearly
everywhere else in Europe was
ill-prepared for the enormity of this
crisis there is a shortage of protective
clothing and as for beds even sports
halls are being converted into wards the
warning here is about ending the
lockdown too soon overwhelmed the medics
fear this could just be the beginning
and a second outbreak could be even more
devastating
Alex Rossy Sky News